At age 15, I [decided] to leave school. I just you know couldn't do any exam. So I was hopeless
[I] never felt like a victim. I think in movies really helped me kind of saved me from shame take this
obstacle and make it the reason
To have a big life. I felt horrible growing up. I always felt on the outside. It makes you so emotional
Why is that?
We all have these limiting beliefs that hold us back [from] success in our lives
We believe that we can't go out and accomplish our goals because of this one particular
[reason] that we feel is holding us back or what I found with with a little bit of a perspective shift a
Mindset shift you can turn that negative
Living and belief the thing that you thought was holding you back and turn it into a superpower that helps propel you forward
You can live life with no limits, [so] today we're going to look at the dySlexia advantage
When I was at school, I would look at a blackboard and I would
not understand anything on that blackboard and
At age 15, I decided to leave school. I just you know couldn't do any exams. I was hopeless
when I went out into the real world and I came across things that I was interested in and I think I could get a
better grasp on it than most people and
Because I was a dyslexic. I was also very good at finding
other really good people to surround myself with good people who could compensate for my weaknesses and
and it taught me to be [a] very good delegator [witch] which is very important of your running businesses and
and
And I think you know the advice I give to mothers. Who've got dyslexic children is you know let them?
[don't] force them too hard on the things they find the difficult, but they will exceed excel on
on some other areas and push them into those other areas and
and
and a lot of you know a lot of the
Most successful people in [the] world were once or are dyslexic from my 20s. [I] started talking about the fact that
You know that I've discovered that it was dyslexic
and
and I did it on purpose because I think
it's important for
Other you know especially young kids who've been told that they're dyslexic to see that
you know the successful people you know can get through it and
And that you know if they follow their particular dreams. They follow what they're good at that
you know that they could be they can be even more successful at what they're good at than
others, so
And there are so many people like myself who have excelled in [their] you know individual
professions
Who have been dyslexic so I think it?
I think it really I think it's really important that you know people who are dyslexic get get out and talk about it
yeah, I mean, I am dyslexic and
and therefore, I think I've been very good at keeping things simple because
You know as a dyslexic. I need to need things to be simple for myself and therefore virgin I think
You know when we launched a financial service company or a bank. You know we do not use jargon
it's everything is very clear-cut very simple and
And I think people you know people have an affinity to the virgin brand because we don't
You know we don't talk above them or talk down to them
as having been dyslexic for my entire life and
Which explained a lot of things it was like the last puzzle part in a tremendous mystery
That I've kept to myself [all] these years that [basically] started with just things that happen when you're a kid in school
And you're a slow reader yeah, and in my case. I was actually um
enabled to read for for at least two years
[I] was two years behind the rest of my class and of course I went through what everybody goes through is teasing yeah
And I had to go through that for a long time and so the teasing you know led to a lot of other problems I
Was having in school, but it all stemmed from the fact that I was embarrassed to
Stand up in [front] of the class and and and and and read
But I never felt like a victim that was the important thing. [I] never felt like a victim
I think movies really helped me kind of save me from shame from
From guilt from putting it on myself when it wasn't really you know you know my own burden
It wasn't my burden, and I think making movies was my [great] [escape]
That's really how I was able to get away from all of that
and you think that can kind of show through your movies you show and like how you felt or
You know just what you felt about the world or what you felt about
people
Teasing you I guess or what you were going through not really my first movies didn't do that
My first movies were just basically imitations in movies
I was going out [to] theaters to [see] so they were pure
You know genre movies you know war movies western science fiction and and there were no statements. I made no statement
I'm talking about my eight millimeter movies. I'm going way back before I became a director and
and I'm just saying that in in in light of
Feeling a little bit like an outsider
Movies made me feel inside my own [skillset] and the other thing is I'm [in] a business right [now]
We're reading is very important. You know it's going to it's of critical importance to me that I read books and
scripts and and and and so I've been able to
Overcompensate and I just basically with the note with never feeling ashamed of myself will take
You know two hours and 45 minutes to three hours to read a 120 pages takes me about
Two hours 45 minutes to read what most people can read in about an hour and 10 minutes?
And I just know I'm still slow at reading but I've learned to
Adjust I just don't I read often but I'm very here's a great thing also
I have great comprehension in what I read because I do read slowly
I retain almost everything. I read I don't just skip over things yeah, and I'm able to appreciate the writing
I'm able to kind of really savor. Good writing because I really take my time going through a book or a script if you had
Any advice to get for young kids who have dyslexia and who are just finding out what they're going [through] now
What would you tell them just that it's more common than you?
Could imagine and that you're not alone and that there are ways to
Accelerate your reading skills to accelerate your comprehension, and there are ways to deal with it. It's not an incurable thing
It's something you're going to have the rest of your life
But you can sort of you know dart between the raindrops to get where you want to go and it will not hold you back
Do you think [your] dyslexia got you to where you are today? [I'm] sure it. Had a large a large hand in it
Yeah, and the fact that since I was born
[I've] always known I want to pretend to put myself in other time periods to be able to
Pretend to be another species. I mean that stuff to me is interesting [and] and it helps my mind
Excellent. Yeah, it's our way of escaping the real life, and I guess normal people can't really do that
They have a harder time. I think they have a very hard time and for that
I got you to know I think the advantage is my brain
sees and
Puts information in my head differently mm-hmm sometimes more interestingly
I think then then if I saw like everyone else
[I] think it's less challenging now because we have some idea [about] it
But I think the challenge will always be how we see ourselves
not as
folks with a handicap but folks
with an interesting perspective on everything or
Just hold on to your dreams, and you [know] never ever think that you're not good enough, or that you're stupid
you know never let anyone tell you that you're stupid or that you know you're not capable because
It's a human issue. Isn't it it's like it's it's it's mostly a human issue. You know we are. We're all the [same]
We're all equal and you know and we deserve a shot and I would just say you know
Take take this
obstacle and
Make it the reason
To have a big life
because if you can climb and if you can overcome that obstacle
You're going to be that much further ahead than anyone else because it takes having obstacles
To you know to learn and grow and be better. You know it's like if it was smooth plane sailing
You know what do you what? [do] you know? What do you become if you're a straight-a student, maybe maybe that's great
Maybe I'm sure there are plenty of straight-a students who end up smoking pot
[take] [a] [nap] you're not I mean insane but but the obstacle
The the Mountain [that] is that the challenge of climbing that dySlexia is is something that you can?
Make your own and make it a reason to be a winner in life
Found out that you had what [you] had to slice it, but way later on in your life
Right I found out when I was 31 you know, what inspired me. Here's the thing I felt horrible
Growing up. I always felt on the outside
I always felt like I was stupid like I couldn't figure out concepts and what what I?
My my message is you have greatness in you not one of the children sitting here?
Does not have greatness in them
And it is really important that they know that and that school is the law maybe school is difficult
But when you get out, you soar like an eagle [it] is not the money
It's just the way you see the child is an individual and and what it is they need and it's not a matter of coddling
It's not a matter of spoiling
but if a herd child to me is a powerful child if a child feels like
Somebody is paying attention
They feel differently about themselves, and that's just the truth
so let me just say to all the children [that] are listening every one of you is powerful, and
School does not define you you
Define yourself. I'm not [kidding]. You're wonderful
What was it like?
being here and
Not being the smartest kid in the class you know we didn't call it dick selects the event it was called Smarten up
It's not not smarten up [Jay] was dyslexic
and you know that a lot of his time in the principal's office for
Pulling pranks or laying rubber in the parking lot, and I think his parents were very
Concerned about what was going to happen to him. You know I had a wonderful teacher in English teaching me. They Mrs. Hawkes
She said you know I always see telling stories and making jokes
Why don't you take my creative writing class, [and] I'll give you a credit in English for that
And you write some of these stories down
Maybe good reading to the class did that change you at all yeah, because it was the first time in my life
I actually focused on something. I was when I would do homework would be okay 16 times fine. What's that a fly? Oh?
You know I mean, I would just never focus on anything. So that [was] the first time my life. I think I really
focused on something he turned out to be
the famous One the Rich one the
And he and I think he did that because [he] worked so hard
you
Did they try and encourage you to be better, or did they just sweep you to the side now?
I went into special needs classes
Which is about four kids that went up had special extra classes and stuff and yeah my teachers were lovely
but I don't think that we were as
strategically as advanced
As we are now I think we're much better at it now, [but] [also] we didn't recognize DySlexia
It was like an on/off button you're even dyslexic and you had to literally be looking through [2] inch glasses
Or you know and I think you know now
We know as many forms of it and and and I don't think I'm deeply held back by DySlexia
But I mean undoubtably I've got it
but you know I think I think [I] was given all the support for the time and
it just wasn't my place to shine really I had a kid [come] up to me the other day and
He can't sometimes you read about stuff like this
we don't exist that it's a real emotion and this kid must have been about 10 and
He came up to me and said I heard you're dyslexic. I said yes
I am and he said have you ever felt that you're worth [nothing] and
I'm like
No, why why do you think do you feel that and he's like yeah?
That's the stage when you got a start
Worrying because it doesn't you know but being dyslexic or or having any special needs is not an excuse or a reason for you to?
Not prosper. [it's] just you're [not] going to be good at the predictable things, but you know I mean there's wonderful people in business and
Architecture and art and music that have had learning difficulties and
But I think what that kid was tapping into is is that every single one of us need to feel like we're good at something
Otherwise we feel like you know
And he obviously did so I had a little pep talk with him anyway for sort of 10 10 minutes
And hopefully hopefully it made a difference. I told him to come and see me in he was 16 I
Said I'll give you a job really what I'm talking about [Self-esteem]
And that you know that can be relevant to anyone regardless of DySlexia or not really?
after I started to talk about
this being dyslexic
And as I researched it. I have to really look at it, and say it's an asset um and I think the asset is that
when I had to read something I had to read it five times when
You know I got saw the opportunity of co-op to go to school one week and work the other I went to work
I always just visualized and concentrate on things because
maybe the Theory is
We're not getting you know dyslexics
don't get caught up reading books and reading how it should be done and go out and
Execute how it should be done, right and it's funny out. You know I walk in a room
Especially I'll do speaking game over 5,000 people. I say how many people in here [are] dyslexic
nobody four people raised their hand right, and it's usually the
Ceos and very very powerful people that [raised] their hands, but people that work within
environments their shame
And they're afraid and they don't say and then I start to give them the stats
About will Smith and Tom cruise and myself and the four sharks and then also in every way [there] were dyslexic
raising their hand so but I just want obviously to bring this awareness to people, and it's nothing to be ashamed of
Absolutely not and uh you know we want to make sure that people get you know got tested if they feel that
You know there's a challenge as a learning challenge
okay, so
Dyslexia you might have this and
Teachers you might see kids who might be suffering from this you can look this stuff at you can find that
But you can get help and stuff gets better in life
So if you're having a tough time of it now, don't worry about it too much
But reach out talk to parents talk [to] friends talk to teachers
Talk to everyone, and there's a hashtag you can look this up then to the vote alone. You know a dyslexic
[you] know a dyslexic [now] you have to stay off the spell [that] they have to spell [know]
With a this is tricky it should just be ping it should be hashtag king, but it's ashtag you know it is lecture anyway
There's the hashtag put that in and you win a sausage, and you can get your like that and stuff will come up
Yes stuff will come up on that. Which will help you
There it is
things can get better and will get better if you have to take action upon it action do things to make this change and then
you can be a crazy person [like] me and have painted fingernails and
Living talking with the words that were the problem in the spelling and you'd be given this thing which [looks] like a negative
But you could turn it into a positive
That's my message to you, so take this stick it in your pipe, and smoke it. Thank you goodbye
You're dyslexic. Yes, you learned that at a really a pretty young [age] I was
Dyslexic and very very much, so it was very challenging for me
I couldn't read in early ages, and it really affects her your reading score it gets you pushed back
But there was a woman named marjorie garlic who's very famous out of a university McGill with Sam, Rabinovich?
And I became part of an experimental class
they were testing an idea at the time and
It was my mother that got me in that class she kind of
Made sure that I got in there somehow and I thank her so much for it their thesis
went like this
You feel so weird when you're dyslexic
because and I can still do this I can read upside down I can read in a mirror and
What marjorie said was look this is not a fault you have a superpower
And when you're that young [you] buy into that it gives you the confidence you need and that's what occurred to me
she gave me that confidence and
That carried you a long way yeah
It makes you so emotional. Why is that?
Well excuse me. I just I think of those days. I think people only see your hard
Shell yeah, and they probably think that you never ran into challenges like that
They were very tough times because I was I was really wondering if I was ever going to make it
I was it was you [know] those were very tough times
[I] was failing [there] was a lot of panic in my own family my teachers
Weren't sure and I knew it was a it was I was very lucky
I was very lucky, and I meet lots of dyslexic people today, and I give them encouragement because it's it is a superpower
Thank you guys so much for watching. I hope you enjoyed I'd love to know what you thought of this video
It's part of a new series that I'm thinking about creating called
No
limits where we look at
Limiting beliefs that [people] [have] around certain issues [that] they feel a holding themselves back and then showcasing people who have those same issues
And yet go on to achieve massive success, so this one looked at DySlexia
And we're potentially looking at looking at other issues in the future
So let me know what you think should we continue this series?
What did you think about this one leave it down the comments below I'm going to join in the discussion
Thank you guys again for watching [I] believe in you. I hope you continue to believe in yourself and whatever your one
Word is much love. I'll see you soon
you
I always tell the sexist I [talk] to that it dis lecture is actually a gift because it gives you
Talents that other people don't have
It's now very clear that
dyslexics excel at some kinds of
of
occupations for instance there are more
Artists or dyslexics that you expect there are more architects who than you'd expect there are more entrepreneurs than you'd expect
There are more engineers than you'd expect [now] all those things
have a
Something in common that is to say it means you have to have a holistic
Outlook on Life rather than being good at sequential things reading requires
Sequencing sequencing the letters and the words and making sure you know where they are in the right order whereas artists
require really to see a whole
Scene and see how all the bits fit together now dyslexics are much better at [that] than they are at these
Sequential things be clear that there are more
dyslexic 'some um
artists architects ETc, but the it's often argued that that is because
People who are dyslexic about it reading and therefore, they are
diverted away from things that demand a lot of reading into things like artists being an artistic cetera and
but the
balance of evidence now suggests that actually
Dyslexics are not just forced into these
kinds of pursuits, but they are actually
more talented in them, and you can test that in the lab by testing things like
their ability to
see spot figures in a cluttered scenery or
discriminate colors a lot of
What we call
holistic Kinds of visual Spatial tasks
dyslexics are better at and that's absolutely clear so that suggests very strongly that they do have a
Superior Talents that's only to be expected
Actually from a genetic point of your evolutionary point of view the fact is that dySlexia is extremely common
But 10% [of] people have it particularly boys
[that]
Means that there must be compensating advantage because if it was all
Disadvantage that gene or genes we now though at least know there's at least [7] genes
Involved those genes would have disappeared because they you know what one of the things we know is that
many, dyslexics have poor motion discriminate a poor ability to pick up motion and
If you had a really serious
deficit in that regard
You wouldn't see the oncoming Saber-toothed tiger, and you wouldn't live to procreate your genes
So it's quite clear there must be some balancing advantage of being dyslexic
And then it's quite clear from what I've just said that it is this
holistic talent this ability to see things in the round that dyslexics have
Much more than ordinary readers well
I always tell dyslexia sigh talk to that it dyslexia is actually a gift because it gives you
Talents that other people don't have and
I'm sure that that both things are true. That is to say and
children who are dyslexic
Tend to take up pursuits that don't demand too much reading. I would anyway if I couldn't read them in it's very very frustrating
to [be] trying to
read a book and not be able to when your peers can do so
So you tend to do the things you're good at and you're good at
these things that require holistic Vision spatial abilities and
As we I have just said we actually find that
Dyslexics are very good at those kind of pursuits, so it's a combination the two. It's both
the
ability to see things in the round and also and the fact that people odd are
Driven towards those sort of pursuits because they're not very good at reading nobody says they're in opposition
They actually are happy marriage. I would say first
Dyslexics, I met when I was first
Introduced to the whole subject was somebody who was a first wrangler senior wrangler at and at Cambridge
[I] have an extremely good
Mathematician came first in the Math [tripod] and
he was extremely dyslexic and
When I discussed it with him. He said well, the thing was that he was really bad at
Things like arithmetic and adding and subtracting numbers
But as soon as he began to see there were patterns in in Mathematics
He could see patterns that other people couldn't and einstein said the same that he saw things in pictures
He didn't he couldn't work it out sequentially and Einstein's a well-known dyslexic. [it] was a well-known mistake
Well, I'm sure you're right because one of the things and this has never actually been published
But one [of] the things I observed in working with a primary school teacher
Was that the dySlexic children?
were
remarkably good at
drawing
[3-Dimensional] objects because most children say well a three-dimensional object
looks like this
And therefore they draw let's say the top and then they don't know what to do about the bits underneath [whereas] a dyslexic
We'll see how it [actually] looks not how it should look and so they get it right. It's noticeable. There are many
dyslexics among architects and
The reason probably is is that?
Architects need to be able to visualize [how] their buildings are going to look
when they're completely built, and it's very difficult for most people to see that from plans for instance flat plans on a
piece of paper
but
dyslexics are notoriously good at seeing things in three dimensions or and
extrapolating from dimensions into three dimensions because of this holistic ability they have
Richard Rogers the Famous architect who is himself dyslexic?
says that he prefers to have dyslexics in his drawing office or in his architects office because they could
Visualize how a [building's] going to look and he needs that
To be able to know that the buildings can look oh as he wanted to
This is highly controversial, but there seems to be evidence that dyslexics are
Have more activation of the parts of brain that are known to [be]
important
for creativity and so in
functional Magnetic resonance imaging experiments, where you
get dyslexics compared with good readers to
Exhibit creativity, there's a thing called the [torrance] tests of creativity for instance
You could show [that] there's more or some people have shown that
there's more activation in a particular part of the brain than this this part of the brain in the frontal Lobe and
there's more activation of that area in dyslexics particularly in the left hemisphere and
Then in good readers of that correlates with their better
Creativity this means being able to sequence things in [time]
sequence your life as it were and [there] are notoriously bad it dyslexics I've
dealt with you [know] no tourists who [fail] [to]
Turn up on time or turn up two hours earlier that sort of thing because they don't have that
Absolutely embedded sequencing style that most of us get through
education early in life, but
[that] has it's good side as well because it means that they [are] open to [new]
suggestions, new ideas
And that's probably one of the things that contributes to their artistic talents another aspect of this is because
They have such bad time trying to learn to read if they survive their schooling. They will have
Developed means of getting over this plus a great deal of determinate yeah, one of the things I'm convinced that
Explains why I want among entrepreneurs
dyslexic so 10 times
over-Represented than you'd expect
and it's because
Through the knocks of life particularly during education. They've had to
Become very resilient [they've] made lots of mistakes
And they've had to work way out ways [around] these mistakes and as a consequence. They are extremely determined and
Successful because they don't give up